president Trump decides to jump on all
of the rakes simultaneously California
continues to collapse and big business
undercuts its own case I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
well you gotta love that feeling when
you set up an entire podcast and you've
got the entire schedule laid out for you
and then President Trump just blows it
up because it's a day ending and why
well today President Trump decided it
was time to jump into the middle of
another controversy so we had seen
several weeks of controversy several
months of controversy really over
Rasheeda Talib and Ilhan Omar and the
entire anti-semitic contingents in the
Democratic Party and in the broader
media defending Rasheeda Talib and Ilhan
Omar over their anti-semitism we got see
Ilhan Omar Risha Talib pledging to take
a trip to Israel which they called
Palestine with a group so anti-semitic
at once pushed the blood libel we got to
see the entire media full of
firefighters intrepid strong
firefighters completely ignore that
story and instead say that Israel is
super super super bad for not allowing
in people who explicitly say they are
joined with a group that wants to
destroy the State of Israel and we got
to see the spectacle of members of the
media defending Omar and Talib from the
cruel predations of people who disagreed
with them because they were the real
victims here they were the real victims
here now our intrepid journalistic
firefighters really doing incredible
work so that was the narrative all
president Trump had to do was point out
that the media we're not doing their
jobs all he had to do is point out that
were shooted talib in Doha Omar are what
they are which is people who do not like
Jews that's all he had to do but
President Trump he's not a man who is
going to stick to the script he's not a
person who is going to stick to the
winning strategy no president Trump is
going to find all of the rakes and jump
on them simultaneously like Sideshow Bob
in an episode of The Simpsons and so
President Trump decided yesterday that
would be brilliant to comment on Omar
and Talib and he started off in a place
that is not terrible and then he went to
a place that is quite not good here is
the President of the United States
jumping on all of the rakes and then
falling over into a minefield and then
falling into the rotors of a helicopter
where's the Democratic Party gun where
have they gone where their defense
these two people over the state of
israel and i think any jewish people
that vote for a democrat I think it
shows either a total lack of knowledge
or great disloyalty
okay great disloyalty is the problem
with this statement great disloyalty if
he wants to say that Jews who are voting
for a party to defend a Lahaina Omar and
Rasheeda Talib are showing the lack of
knowledge that maybe in politic that's a
fair statement if he wants to say that
rashid it to leave in ohon omar
radically anti-israel as a fair
statement once you get into charges of
disloyalty you're getting into very ugly
territory now let's be honest about this
president Trump is not clear on what
exactly he is saying here he's not
because he doesn't make clear what he is
saying about this loyalty who are these
American Jews disloyal to are they
disloyal to other Jews are they disloyal
to the State of Israel which would be a
dual loyalty charge which would be
anti-semitic saying they should be loyal
to Israel instead of to their priorities
in the United States is he saying
they're disloyal to Judaism it sort of
depends what he is talking about there
to determine whether he is actually
engaging in an to in an antisymmetric
are they being disloyal to trump do they
owed from their loyalty because Trump is
pro-israel which goes back to the dual
loyalty smear that so many Democrats
have engaged in over the years so the
non clarity of what he's saying is a
problem and I think we do have to break
this down because there is a there is a
way to read the statement that is not
anti-semitic and then there are ways to
read the statement that are anti-semitic
or at least engaged in anti-semitic
probes so that break this down in a
little bit of detail here so stick with
me I know we've had a lot of jewy talk
lately that's not my fault okay that is
just because there are a lot of
anti-semites out there lately
and then the president decided to make
this the top issue of the day so let's
begin with a simple fact when people
reference Jews very often they're not
clear about what they're talking so are
they referencing ethnic Jews like people
who are born into a Jewish family or are
they talking about people who are Jews
by religion so this is not quite the
same thing so there many Jews who are
ethnic Jews who are not Jewish by
religion in fact the majority of Jews in
the United States are irreligious only
40% of Jews in the United States ethnic
Jews believe in God or really have a
connection with Judaism in any sort of
way so when people say why do you choose
vote Democrat my usual answer is because
most Jews aren't particularly Jewish
most Jews don't actually practice
Judaism
because you have a name ending in
Steinbaum or goldberg does not mean that
you are actively practicing Judaism in
any real way okay so you have to
distinguish between the practice of
Judaism the philosophy of Judaism and I
am a philosophic Jew right I wear a
yarmulke I'm a religious Jew you can
read all about my religious beliefs and
my philosophic beliefs in my book the
right side of history which is variants
Const in a lot of biblical thinking
right that there's religious and
philosophical Judaism and then there is
ethnic Judaism which is no I'm Chomsky
is an ethnic Jew Bernie Sanders is an
ethnic Jew now to me I think Judaism
doesn't matter because I don't really
care about it I don't care about
tribalism and thus I don't care about
what you were born into I care about
what you think I don't care about your
genetic status I care about what you
think and this holds true whether you
are black white green or Jewish it does
not matter to me okay so we have to make
that distinction because that's actually
an important distinction for what we're
about to discuss going forward we'll get
to more of this in just one second I'll
continue the explanation first let's
talk about the earbuds that you are
using to listen to this show so Rickon
earbuds started about half the price of
any other premium wireless earbuds on
the market and they say on just as good
you're probably listening on some of
those old-fashioned earbuds that have
the wires attached them or you have
earbuds that have stems or you just paid
a fortune for earbuds and you're looking
for a second pair that isn't gonna cost
you an arm and a leg well this is what
rake on a 50 wireless earbuds come in
they've totally changed the game for me
because not only are they stylish they
are also extremely comfortable and they
sound really really good rake on earbuds
are discreet there no dangling wires no
stems and of course they don't just look
great they sound great as well ray Cano
offers their wireless earbuds for
everyone in range of fun colors at an
unbeatable price go buy go to buy rake
on Comm slash been to get 15% off your
order
that's bu y ra y co n comm slash been
for 15% off rake on wireless earbuds if
you've been eyeing a pair now would be
the time to get an amazing deal one more
time buy rake on Comm slash Ben that's
Bui RA Y Co n comm slash been buy rake
on comm slash meddling to use that slash
pen you get 15% off your order okay so
as I say when people reference Jews they
have to be clear about what they're
talking when they say Jews do mean
ethnic Jews like people who are born
Jewish or people who practice Judaism in
some real way and that makes a
difference when you're discussing how
people vote because obvious
if you're talking about the first brand
of Judaism if you're talking about
people who are just born ethnic Jews
then to suggest that all those people
must have loyalties in a particular
direction that is that is just
anti-semitism because just because
you're born into a particular tribe or
into a particular family doesn't mean
you have to believe anything that is no
better and no worse than Ayane Presley
the congresswoman who's a member of the
squad saying just a few weeks ago we
don't need any more Brown faces that
don't want to be a brown voice but that
was her using tribal loyalty as some
sort of litmus test and that is racist
and it's anti-semitic to say all Jews
have to think the same way and by Jews I
mean everybody who was born Jewish and
is ethnically Jewish that's very silly
just because you were born one way
doesn't mean that's how you have to
think right so that is take number one
remember I Ana Presley did say this the
media didn't care about it at the time
but she did say precisely the same thing
that people supposed from said about
Jews except about brown people and black
people if you were not prepared to come
to that table and so represent that
voice don't come because we don't need
any more Brown faces that don't want to
be a brown voice please don't even show
up okay you remember that that she
remember she said this no one care she's
also in in this particular quote Ayanna
Presley I'm not just diverting Twyla
Presley here I'm not I think it's
actually important that she lumped in
brown face brown voices and black voices
and black faces and Muslim faces I think
it is actually fair to say that certain
philosophies are mirrored in politics so
for example if I say I don't understand
why a practicing Catholic would vote
democrat democrats are pro-abortion
I don't understand why a practicing
Catholic would vote Democrat there's
nothing anti-catholic about that if I
said everyone who was born into a
Catholic family must vote Republican
that would be very weird that would be a
weird thing to say right to say that if
you're Muslim that that takes into
account certain ideological preferences
because Islam is a religion meaning that
it is a philosophy that has embedded in
it certain ideas and therefore you
should reflect those ideas in your
public life if you proclaim yourself a
Muslim voice I don't see anything
particularly wrong with that I don't see
anything particularly wrong with saying
about Judaism this is why I've said for
a long time that when you see groups
like Jewish Voice for Peace that they
are Jews in name only meaning that
they're ethnic Jews but they are not
actually representing any sort of
philosophic Judaism in any real way and
in fact they are using Judaism as a club
to wield against Jews very often okay so
as I say couple points different scene
ethnic Jews and religious Jews and two
people who are born Jewish don't have to
have political loyalties in any
direction and to suggest that they do is
anti-semitic here now grouping all Jews
by dint of birth as in a certain
ideological or philosophical group and
that of course is untrue hey three
American Jews whether they are ethnic or
religious are loyal to America not
Israel so if the implication of
President Trump saying that you are
disloyal if you don't vote for Trump
because you're actually willed to Israel
okay that is a pure dual loyalty smear
and that is anti-semitic a fourth is
what from could be saying that would not
be anti-semitic hey Jewish belief and
practice should in fact make it very
difficult to vote for a party that
celebrates and champions Jew haters like
we're schita to leave in no Hanauma
undoubtedly yes it should be much harder
for people who care deeply about
religious and philosophic Judaism to
vote for a party that makes common cause
with Rasheeda Talib and Ilhan Omar just
as it would not be ridiculous to say
that it's very difficult to suggest that
Jewish belief and practice would allow
you to vote labor in Britain a party
that has steadily moved away from Israel
which is connected to Jewish belief in
practice a party that has not only
undercut Israel but undercut religious
liberty in the United States that has
favored specific groups
if those groups are even if they're
targeting Jews like Omar and Talib are
in at the intersectional coalition that
is throwing Jews outside the circle of
victimhood for their own political
purposes there is nothing wrong with
saying that philosophic and religious
Judaism makes it very difficult to vote
for the party that does all of those
things just as it's not wrong to say
that Muslims should take into account
how Muslims believe when they vote or
Christians should take into account how
Christians believe when they vote
there's nothing anti-anything okay to
suggest again that that if you are a
practicing Jew that if you care about
you to use them in any way that you
should take accounts of those values
when you vote I don't really see a
problem
with that and here is where Trump's lack
of clarity is particularly damning for
him it's completely unclear if from
statistics suggests that all Jews must
be loyal to Israel which would be
anti-semitic or that all Jews by dint of
birth ought to believe a certain thing
which of course would be anti-semitic as
well or that Jews who take Judaism
seriously should vote for Donald Trump
which is an argument it may be an
awkward argument for Trump to make it
maybe a self aggrandizing argument but
at least it's an argument that is not
anti-semitic right it's an argument that
in many ways is kind of true okay well
this brings us to this morning so this
morning President Trump decided you know
what gonna double down cuz that's what
we always do here instead of explaining
than what he means is that Jews who take
Judaism seriously ought to of course
favor his administration because he's
been incredibly pro-israel because he's
been incredibly Pro Jewish because this
president has been a great friend to the
American Jewish community in a lot of
ways which all of which is true instead
President Trump decided to go on Twitter
and then unleash the single dumbest
tweet thread I've seen from him in some
time and that that is saying something
so he tweeted out from Wayne Allyn root
some Wayne Allyn root is a is a radio
host and commentator and Wayne Allyn
root said some silly things today and
Trump decided to retweet them out into
the world he said Trump said quote thank
you to Wayne Allyn root for the very
nice words quote this is from Wayne
Allyn root President Trump is the
greatest president for Jews and for
Israel in the history of the world not
just America he is the best president
for Israel in the history of the world I
think again there's a case we made for
this this is the president who did move
the US Embassy from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem this is the president who
acknowledged Israel's rights of the
Golan Heights this is a president who's
been overtly pro-israel in all of his
statements and all of his speeches that
part's not the wrong part hey and then
we now and continued the Jewish people
in Israel love him this is true by poll
numbers and then we get to the weird
part
Trump remember this is Trump retweeting
stuff about himself they love him like
he's the king of Israel like Trump is
the king of Israel well now I get an
awkward dude because you're not King
David and if you mean like another king
of Israel the Jews are not famous for
their worship for Jesus and as it turns
out Wayne Allyn root
talking about Jesus when he says king of
Israel quote they love him like he is
the second coming of God
now I'm not a New Testament expert but I
do know some things about the Old
Testament and about the Jews and
suggesting as Donald Trump is doing in
the suite that he's like the second
coming of Jesus and therefore the Jews
loved him he may have missed the whole
point of the part where the Jews are not
Christian he may miss that whole part
where the Jews were not big on the first
coming this is getting real awkward dude
gettin real awkward and crazy and then
Trump says American Jews don't know him
or like him they don't even know what
they're doing or saying anymore it makes
no sense but that's okay if he keeps
doing what he's doing
he's good for all Jews blacks gays
everyone more importantly he's good for
everyone in America who wants a job wow
that's a Trump adds that Wow at the end
okay again if you are saying that
American Jews should be closely it
should practice Judaism and therefore
they should have different priorities
it's a it's a call to religion from from
Trump that would be kind of strange but
not anti-semitic it is very weird that
the president is calling himself the
King of the Jews and the second coming
of God by dint of retweet that is that
is bizarre okay now with all of that
said with all of this said and again I
have opened wide the possibility that
Trump was using anti Semitic language
here right I mean I've explicitly
acknowledged two ways in which this
could be interpreted that we ran C's
medic and one way in which it would not
be and my inclination is that Trump is
an ignoramus because that is all my
that's always my inclination I don't
think Trump is he is a Jew hater in the
way that Omar and Talib ax are as
evidenced by the fact he's not calling
for the destruction of the State of
Israel he's not suggesting that the only
support for the State of Israel in
America is due to Jewish money that it's
all about the Benjamins and that this
president may engage in root
stereotyping and he does this on a
regular basis with a variety of groups
and it's ugly
and it's wrong but my inclination is
that that's because the president is not
up on the political jargon and this is
not me letting him off the hook for any
of this but what do you think rings more
true that Trump hates Jews in the way
that Omar and Salib obviously do or that
President Trump is just an ignoramus who
doesn't know how to use the English
language would seem
to ring true in a variety of ways
because that's what he is
that's what he's now in one second we're
gonna get to the great irony of the
media turning this into the story of the
day and get to the great irony of that
because there is a great irony in this
okay first my home had really ugly
blinds and I kept wondering what was
making my home look so dingy and then I
realized it was the window coverings and
that's why I went to blinds.com good
blinds are to a home what a sharp tie is
to a suit it brings it all together but
going blind shopping isn't something I
particularly enjoy you probably don't
either it's not like oh it's a Sunday
afternoon let's go shopping for blinds
blinds calm though makes it really fast
and really easy which is why I like them
with 15 million windows covered and over
30,000 five-star customer reviews
blinds.com is America's number one
online retailer for affordable quality
custom window coverings blinds.com makes
the whole experience fast and easy plus
every order gets free samples free
shipping a free online design
consultation if you want to upgrade your
house and not spend a fortune the best
way to do it is to upgrade those window
coverings you probably haven't even
thought about the window coverings in
your house you really should they make a
huge difference when you walk into a
nice place and you look at the window
coverings really think about it for a
second it really does make the whole
place look completely different and
blinds that con makes it super easy you
can send them pictures of your home they
send back custom recommendations from a
professional for what will work with
your color scheme and your furniture and
specific rooms if you screw it up you
accidentally mismeasure they will remake
your blinds for free they've made it
super easy there is no excuse to have
the crappy blinds up in your living room
for a limited time my listeners get 20
bucks off at blinds comm when you use
promo code Ben that's blinds.com promo
clip Ben for 20 bucks off faux wood
blinds cellular shades roller shades and
more blindness com promo code Ben rules
and restrictions do indeed apply okay so
the media have jumped all over Trump
over these comments and again I think
criticism of Trump over the comments is
do I think that the comments are easily
read in a way that is not the proper way
to talk about religious or philosophical
ISM right I myself have talked about bad
Jews before and what I mean by bad Jews
is Jews who invoke Judaism as I
mentioned like J like J Street or Jewish
Voice for Peace cynically and an attempt
to use Judaism as a substitute for
progressive values that runs directly
counter to Judea
I don't mean Jews who don't practice
Judaism there are lots of Jews who don't
practice Judaism many members of my
family are Jews who don't particularly
practice Judaism that is their choice
okay well make somebody a bad Jew in my
view is somebody who is using the tenets
of Judaism cynically and overtly in
order to undermine a lot of Jewish
tenets but you do see this okay but that
is a discussion within philosophic
Judaism that is not discussion with an
ethnic Judaism okay with all of that
said it is unbelievable that the members
of the media are jumping all over this
why because the members of the media I
have spent the last several weeks
blatantly ignoring Omar and Talib trying
to tour Israel with a group that pushed
the blood libel and push the idea that
Jews drink Christian blood on Passover
and with a group that was quoting from
neo-nazi websites the same media those
those real intrepid firefighters in our
media we're focused in like a laser beam
on Donald Trump today don't give a damn
when it's anti-semitism from the other
side and I've been complaining about
this for years at this point the New
York Times has openly admitted that they
have not been reporting on local
anti-semitic crime because it doesn't
fall into the category of white
supremacist crime in other words they
only care about anti-semitism when it's
time to use anti-semitism as a charge
against a Republican or against a
conservative or against people who they
can associate with Republicans or
conservatives right when they can try
and tie together white supremacists and
Trump then they're worried about
anti-semitism but when it comes from
Omar and Talib then no no this is just
the Jews those crafty Jews crafty Jews
you know they're always trying to
infiltrate the media and push their push
their censorship trying to silence
people of color pretty incredible pretty
incredible
you're not fighting anti-semitism unless
you're calling it out on all sides
you are willing to call it out when you
see it I've called it out when I see it
from President Trump I have called it
out when I see it
from people on the right I've called it
out when I see it from people on the
left but I'm not gonna take it under
advisement
when commentators for Al Jazeera who
spend their lives defending the
anti-semitism of Ilhan Omar and Rasheeda
Talib are out there doing this routine
oh woe is them yes I am sure that at the
Democrats who are deeply defending Omar
and Talib today I'm sure that the same
Democrats who refused to condemn Ilhan
Omar statements refused to censor her
and instead passed a resolution against
hate more broadly I'm sure that they are
very disturbed by anti-semitism today
guys
I am super certain that they are really
disturbed by that sort of thing in fact
I am sure the Democrats are incredibly
disturbed whenever anybody suggests that
a group is their loyalty to a politician
if anybody any politician would suggest
that a group chose a specific racial
group owes their loyalty to a politician
or owes their loyalty to a set of causes
on the basis of race I am sure that the
media would be just as upset like let's
say well just for the sake of argument
the Barack Obama back in 2016 - exactly
I'm sure everyone would have gone nuts
right Obama never would have done
something like that ever ever yeah
there's no such thing as a vote that
doesn't matter it all matters and after
we have achieved historic turnout in
2008 and 2012 especially in the
african-american community I will
consider it a personal insult an insult
to my legacy if this community lets down
its guard and fails to activate itself
in this election you want to give me a
good send-off
the ADI personal disloyalty an act of
personal disloyalty undermining Barack
Obama's personal legacy if black voters
don't show up to vote for Hillary
Clinton weird seems like he's accusing
them of disloyalty if they don't do what
he wants on the basis of their race very
strange very said I remember when the
media went crit nope not at all
in other words it seems as though two
things can be true at once Trump can say
a bad thing Trump can say an ignorant
thing from can say a crazy thing about
king of the Jews and second coming of
God and all of this kind of stuff Trump
can do all of that stuff and also the
media can be sheer garbage and I don't
trust them to call out anti-semitism
because they don't do it because they
don't do it I'm not going to listen to a
bunch of people who have made excuses
for anti-semitism at four years so long
as it comes from the right is so long as
it comes from the correct side of the
aisle so long as it comes from the left
anti-semitism is fine so long as it
comes from a group that is higher on the
intersectional pyramid of victimhood
than the Jews then anti-semitism is
totally cool and we'll ignore it now
they're up in arms because Donald Trump
is dog whistling don't you see forget
the bull horns over here
forget Omar and Talib standing over here
shouting at the top of their voice that
they hate Jews
forget that forget the fact that they
retweeted from mondo Weiss yesterday Dan
see somatic website forget the fact that
in the last four days they retweeted a
cartoon from a guy who placed in a Iran
Holocaust denial cartoon contest forget
all of that right that doesn't matter
the only thing matters is that Trump and
Trump said some bad stuff today again
call out Trump by all means do it
because this discourse is ugly and it's
wrong
especially if he meant it in the way
that he seems to have meant it which is
that all ethnic Jews have to vote a
certain way because they were born into
the Jewish community or something like
that
that is a wrong thing to say or if he
meant it like all Jews are more loyal to
Israel than America and therefore they
that has to be their top priority right
if you meant it that way if you meant it
in the way that I have talked about it
when I say that a lot of Jews don't care
about Judaism well then I don't see
anything wrong with that frankly I've
said it myself and when I say that that
when I say that a lot of Jews don't care
very much about Judaism that is true by
poll statistics it is true by absolute
data and so I don't find it a mystery
when a lot of Jews don't support the
more pro-israel party or the more Pro
religious freedom or the mole Pro or the
more pro-life party I don't find that a
big surprise
because that's been true in the Jewish
community for years the the Orthodox
community in the United States vote
somewhere around seventy thirty
Republican and the rest of the Jewish
community votes like eighty twenty
Democrat so that is that that is not a
in any way shape or form so it depends
on what Trump meant here but by all
means call them out when he does
something wrong but if you're asking me
to trust the editors of the New York
Times in five minutes ago or apologizing
for printing anti-semitic cartoons of
their own who've spent years
promulgating the myth that there is
moral equivalence between the State of
Israel and terrorists trying to murder
Jews in the heart of the state of Israel
the same members of the media who are
happy to host Peter Bernard a
spokesperson for Hamas in essence yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna take that with uh
when I say a grain of salt what I really
mean is a giant vat of salt I mean a vat
of salt the size of the Dead Sea that's
how much salt I'm gonna take that with
because I think that you guys are
completely full of crap many things can
be true once Trump can say a bad thing
and also you guys are utterly and
completely and intensely full of garbage
fold excrement and we'll get to in a
second you break down in the state of
California which was the original plan
for today's show we'll get to that in
just a second but first it's hard to
find good employees I mean he'll some
days I feel like firing me and so I've
looked on Zipporah car I can't find an
employee who's good enough to supplant
me at this maybe maybe I'll find
somebody but if I were to find somebody
I'd find that person over at zip
recruiter com if you're looking to
upgrade if you are looking to get rid of
Michael moles and replace him with
someone better a posting that we've had
up on zip recruiter for four years at
this point I know it's just I don't know
there's a personal loyalty thing you
know anyway go over to zip recruiter
calm because zip recruiter calm allows
you to make your business better it
allows you to bring in new employees who
are fantastic
zip recruiter makes it super easy zip
recruiter sends your job posting to over
a hundred of the web's leading job
boards but they don't stop there as
applications come in zip recruiter will
analyze each one and spot like the top
candidates see you never miss a great
match zip recruiter is so effective at
four out of five employers who post on
zip recruiter can equality candidate
through the site within the very first
day and right now my listeners can try
zip recruiter for free at this exclusive
web address zip recruiter comm slash at
Daley wire that zip recruiter comm slash
Dai ly wir
zip recruiter comm slash daily wire zip
recruiter is indeed the smartest way to
hire go check them out right now okay
meanwhile the Democrats are they have to
be thanking their lucky stars that
President Trump is doing what President
Trump does they have to be thanking
their lucky stars because meanwhile they
are tearing themselves apart they don't
know whether they ought to embrace a
middle road or whether they ought to
swing wildly to the left their leading
candidate is a gaffe machine and and
their policies are failing I mean
California is ground zero for democratic
policies and it is a giant giant failure
hey California I've lived here my entire
life I've been here my entire life
except for three years when I was in
Cambridge Massachusetts at Harvard Law
hey I have watched the state deteriorate
I've watched the living conditions in my
area deteriorate even though people are
living in nicer apartments they walk
outside and the ground is strewn with
garbage there are open needles on the
street a few weeks ago I walked out of
my house which is in a nice residential
area and I kid you not right across the
street lying face down in the gutter
like Edgar Allan Poe after a drinking
binge was some person I felt terrible
than some person who is obviously high
lying face down in the gutter nothing
being done about it this is the state of
California now and the state of
California has no answers because the
real answers are free market solutions
and enforcing the laws that are on the
books with regard to criminal trespass
right that is the way that you enforce
this instead nobody will do that so the
idea is that developers do not have a
right to build but homeless people have
the right to sleep on the streets I
wonder why there is so little
development and so many homeless people
I cannot imagine naturally the state of
California is blaming the only people
who are not responsible big business bar
Nene Chakrabarti writing for Fox News so
San Francisco homeless stats sore City
blames big business residents blame
officials it has more billionaires per
capita than anywhere else in the world
but it also has a homeless problem so
severe that arrivals some third world
nations on any given day you can see
souped-up labral guineas and blinged-out
trophy wives in one part of the city and
walk over a few blocks and see piles of
human feces puddles of urine and vomit
caked on the sidewalks the misery of
homelessness mental illness and public
drug addiction hits deep in San
Francisco and has turned parts of a
beautiful
into a public toilet as the problem
grows residents are finding themselves
at a crossroads the compassion for those
struggling is constantly being
challenged by a fear for their own
safety and quality of life it never had
to get this bad sake critics for our pub
that it's getting worse every day well
this is where your mistake compassion
for a failure to enforce the law it is
not compassionate to mentally ill people
to leave them non-medicated on the
street to live in their own filth I
don't know what society believes that
that is a form of compassionate but
apparently that's the government the
government of California Emilia
Cartwright told Fox News I won't visit
my son who lives there it lives out
there again it's disgusting I went there
a few months ago for the first time this
guy who looked homeless and really beat
up spit on me can you imagine he spit on
me well it might be a shock to the
system for some residents say such
interactions are common lately the cases
of citizens being harassed by mentally
ill street people has taken a dangerous
turn last week Austin Vincent a homeless
man was caught on camera attacking a 26
year old woman outside her condo complex
as he threw pennies co Syrian on the
ground he allegedly talked about saving
her from robots and offered to kill
another woman nearby so he could earn
her trust Vincent was arrested and pled
not guilty to a false imprisonment
charge two counts of battery and armed
robbery
instead Superior Court judge Christine
Van Aken released Vincent over the
objections of the DA's office
eventually Vincent had wear an ankle
monitor which means nothing and on
Monday he was arrested again for an
alleged assault that occurred in
February the police said he was armed
with a knife approached a woman and her
friends as they waited for a ride
Vincent allegedly threatened to kill the
woman and lunged at the group the city
still manages to blow through hundreds
of millions of taxpayer dollars each
year to supposedly address the crisis
and blames everyone but themselves when
the homeless count Rises city officials
in May recognized that the homeless
problem that jumped 17% from 2017 and
then that was the preliminary report the
final report showed the street counts
increase would have been 30 percent if
they'd stuck to the same definition of
homelessness as they had in the past
this is insane and it's and it's true in
Los Angeles as well hey it's in Los
Angeles the homeless problem has become
so terrible that their parts of pretty
much every part of the city has been
overrun with people who are living on
the streets hey this is not a question
of wealth redistribution
this is a question of failures of policy
if you're worried about affordable
housing in major cities one of the
things you could do is allow developers
to build but we can't do that
not in Seattle not in LA not in San
Francisco nowhere
how do we know this listen to this story
from USA Today $700,000 for an apartment
the cost to solve the homeless crisis is
soaring in LA Chris Wood you're writing
as the city tries to cope with thousands
of people living on the streets a few
homeless and low-income senior citizens
will be luckier than most next year they
will receive keys to one of 72 new
apartments complete with a fitness
center in the heart of trendy Koreatown
built at a projected cost of $700,000
for each unit according to the city
controllers office controller Ron
galperin said this kind of cost is
utterly unacceptable I believe we need a
fundamental course correction despite a
booming national economy homeless people
have set up tents and makeshift
encampments in major cities on the west
coast amid a housing shortage that has
driven up rents too unaffordable levels
in Los Angeles the tents are spread out
on sidewalks across the city the
homeless emboldened by a court ruling
that allows them to live outside if no
shelter space is available making
matters worse many live in filthy third
world conditions without basic
necessities like toilets and sinks
making people susceptible to disease la
voters passed 1.2 billion dollar bond in
2016 we're gonna spend a bunch of money
on building 10,000 permanent housing
units that would be enough to make a
significant dent in the 28,000 people
deemed living unsheltered in most recent
homeless count the result was a crash
program to construct new apartments
meant as permanent housing the median
cost
$520,000 galperin says by taking a
costly route at the current rate only
somewhat more than 7,000 units will be
constructed far short of the 10,000
leaving thousands on the street hey this
is not merely a problem of lack of
housing this is also a problem with you
shouldn't let people live on the street
you do not have a right to live on the
street in the United States you do not
that is public land you don't have a
right to live in the middle of the
sidewalk creating a public health hazard
Reid Giuliani knew this in New York
which is why New York is no longer a
hellhole LA has turned into a hellhole
it's the saddest thing in Sacramento - I
was just in Sacramento for the weekend
drove past full blocks of people living
in tents full homeless cities according
to the UK Daily Mail a Sacramento salon
owner claims Californian homeless in
this crisis is forcing her to relocate
after 15 years because she has grown
sick of multiple break-ins and cleaning
up syringes urine and feces from outside
her premises every single day
of course this tends to hit
disproportionately poor areas the worst
because richer areas have police
departments that tend to actually move
people if they can the poorer areas are
the ones where everybody is locating on
Skid Row
hey the homeless problem in in LA and
San Francisco and Sacramento is a
disaster area Gavin Newsom the governor
is doing nothing we'll get to these
stupid policies pursued by California
Democrats in order to fight all of this
and they are indeed unbelievably stupid
policies we'll get to that in just one
second first The Daily wire has now
turned four years old congratulations to
us and we are thrilled as a thank you to
our fans we are giving away one month of
our premium monthly subscription to
anyone who uses this code birthday cause
it's our birthday man we can cry if we
wanted that's right for all of August as
we celebrate this bow and this milestone
we're giving away a free first month
four new premium monthly subscribers
again just use the code birthday and
then come and join the fun also believe
it or not tonight
finally is our exciting backstage live
show at the fantastic Terrace Theatre in
Long Beach California I'll be there
daily we're a god-king jeremy boring
will be there Andrew Clavin will be
there Michael moles will be there if you
want that in your life well I'll be
there talking politics pop culture
answering your questions from the
audience
our VIP package sadly is sold out
there's still some generic seats
available for the poppers among you but
you do have to act fast because
literally the event is tonight so you
can't buy it tomorrow because you can't
unless you have a time machine then I
guess you could buy it tomorrow again
tickets are almost gone
heading over to Daley wire.com slash
backstage get yours today also we were
giving away a special gift for me I feel
like I over pitched the special gift for
me I found out what it was yesterday so
I want to apologize in advance it's fine
it's nice it is not the diamond necklace
I plan for you so we'll just have to
deal with that together and experience
the grief as one check us out over at
daily wire comm
slash backstage also make sure to
subscribe over at daily wire $99 a year
gets you this the greatest in all
beverage vessels ahh gaze upon it cast
your eyes upon this
Loree the vessel of glory but from the
second coming of God no no no a
different thing president in any case go
check us out at daily wire.com $99 a
year makes a subscription yours helps us
protect it that helps protect this show
and others like it from the nastiness of
left that seeks 2d platform on a routine
basis we really appreciate it we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so what are the policies that
California is taking in order to fight
back militate against the homelessness
crisis um nothing except making it
harder for people to build units so it
costs too much to live in these cities
supposedly this is the result this is
the cause of the homelessness problem
answer it's not okay the reason that
there are a lot of homeless people on
the street in LA and San Francisco is
because there are nice places to live
you're gonna live on the street you do
it in LA because it ain't cold also it's
because LA and San Francisco have
refused to prosecute people who are
engaged in criminal activity it's also
because LA San Francisco the state of
California they've declared a right for
people to have their crap out on the
street police are not even allowed to
move it I mean there are a lot of
reasons why we've not dealt with the
mental elements problem we've not dealt
with the drug addiction problem we've
not dealt with any of those problem on a
public health level in in that's really
why the homelessness problem is the
thing but according to the left the
homelessness problem is because the rent
is too damn high in the words of a
famous man hey well if the rent is too
damn high you know what you need I'm no
expert but if something costs too much
you probably need more supply just gonna
put that out there you need more supply
naturally this means the state of
California is making it more difficult
to build units genius the California
State Senate is now considering a
measure that would limit rent hikes the
Assembly earlier approved the bill that
would cap rent hikes to 7% plus the rate
of inflation up to a maximum of 10% per
year the measure would apply to all
rentals ten years or older in the
meantime rent control advocates are
backing a new proposition that would
allow rent control for more properties
including apartments at least 15 years
old or single-family homes if the
landlord owns at least three rentals
which will completely destroy the real
estate market in the state of California
which by the way is holding up a lot of
people in their mortgages hey you want a
second real estate crisis this is the
way you do it you make sure that the
real estate values in the state of
California which represent a
disproportionate share of asset
ownership in the state of California
start declining rapidly you want to do
that very easy way to do it make it
impossible to rent those properties make
it so that if you own a second home like
some sort of rental home that we're
gonna be penalized for that so the
market drops out for that the prices
start declining banks
giving loans as quickly people fall into
foreclosure
hey that it'll be it'll be great well
done everybody because what we need is
more people who fall into foreclosure
that'll definitely stop the homelessness
crisis shockingly California developers
are now claiming according to curb calm
that they are scared to build in the Bay
Area there's a shock according to the
UCLA Anderson School of Management and
the law firm Ellen Matt khun's they
released their survey of California
developers they found that those are the
stake in building housing are feeling
gun-shy about the Bay Area you mean it's
hard to build housing in the Bay Area
and maybe that's contributing to the
homelessness crisis no no they're
they're indicating that construction
activity is expected to slow down over
the next 18 months the bay area is a big
exception developers think that in 2022
those areas East Bay San Francisco
Silicon Valley will see worse economics
than in 2019 production of multi-family
homes specifically is expected to
decline those would be exactly the
places that people need to rent just
genius rent control talk is obviously
impacting all of this so you know what
would definitely help what would
definitely help is if let's say the
crime rates in California were also
spiking that would be great so as it
turns out we can make that happen for
you guys we can make the crime rates in
California spike as well the California
crime rates are indeed up they're up
because of realignment they are up
because there has been an attempt to
take people out of prison early an
analysis by the Marshall project in the
LA Times found that while California's
crime rates remain near historic lows
overall crime is up theft has been
rising after California reduced its
criminal penalties according to one
report and the this is obvious ok it is
obvious that that crime has has been a
serious and rising problem in in
California and a lot of the police
departments mean I have lots of friends
on the force in LAPD and a lot of the a
lot of the stats just got fussed by the
political operators in in a lot of these
areas I mean just a few days ago we had
on a police officer from Garden Grove
the chief of Garden Grove police talking
about how realignment had spiked
crime in the city and how this is being
hidden from the public so what's to
blame what's to blame well obviously
what we need is more taxpayer dollars
spent right
being used only one problem
California is basically maxed out
California is raking in the box
according to the Mercury News dan
Walters writing for Cal Matters
he says last week the the State
Department of Finance closed the books
on 2018-2019 revenue and reported that
the state had collected a hundred and
forty five billion dollars 1 billion
more than it had anticipated just weeks
earlier and two billion plus more than
the 2018-2019 budget had originally
forecast that is a whopping 72% more
than the state was collecting one decade
ago outpacing population growth and
inflation the state has enough money to
max out its reserve funds and provide
several billion dollars in extra cash to
offset schools rising pension costs per
pupil spending on K through 12 schools
in California has risen by at least 50%
in recent years ok so this is not a lack
of tax revenue or spending the big
problem in California is that we're just
blowing it out in terms of the spending
we're wasting it on a bunch of crap and
then regulating business is it any
wonder that business is leaving
California our business is located in
California we have conversations nearly
daily about relocating our business out
of California there is a reason for all
of that so the reason that I point out
all of this is that this is a failure of
democratic policy it is a failure of
left policy Republicans have no power in
the state of California this is a
single-party state this is what it looks
like when Democrats are in charge a
problem forms because they refused to
solve a problem then in order to solve
that problem they create another problem
and then they create a third problem on
top of that the only solution is to tax
you more which creates more problems and
then they're surprised when the problems
get created and then the only solution
is to blame business the only solution
is businesses are the culprit of course
businesses are evil now here's where you
would expect business to stand up and
say hold up a second hold up this is not
on us you guys been taking all our money
we pay people exactly what they are
willing to take in the market this isn't
on us we are the ones creating jobs
we're the ones government does not
create the economy government provides
the conditions under which an economy
can flourish but go
does not create the jobs government does
not create the businesses government
does not create any of those things
government in fact hampers those things
business should be defending itself but
because so much of business is now tied
up in public relations because so much
of business is now tied up in pandering
to government for subsidies and tax
breaks because big business and big
government are very often in each
other's pocket you're starting to see
big business under I undermine its own
case for existence so big businesses
case for existence used to be we provide
the jobs we provide the products the
services the goods we provide all of
those things and we do so in a
free-market consent-based way now big
business in an attempt to make cozy with
big government in an attempt to pander
to the left politically is undermining
its own case there's an article in The
New York Times called shareholder value
is no longer everything top CEOs stand
say chief executives from the Business
Roundtable including the leaders of
Apple and JP Morgan Chase argued that
companies must also invest in employees
and deliver value to customers
oh wait III missed it if companies don't
invest in their employees meaning they
don't pay them they're not gonna have
employees and also if they don't deliver
value to their customers aren't they not
gonna have a business businesses that
don't deliver value to their customers
go out of business so what the hell are
we talking about here what we're talking
about is these businesses being forced
into a Maoist struggle session with
left-leaning media and politicians to
declare that really it's our fault
really if we just worked harder you were
right all along
there was a scrooge mcduck money bin in
the backroom and now out of the goodness
of our hearts where I'm walking it hey
do they understand these big business
leaders that the long-term and midterm
effect of what they are doing is to
allow government to take the moral high
ground against free markets this is why
when people say that big business is
capitalism big business is free market
now a lot of big business looks for
government rent-seeking a lot of big
business is looking for government
protection a lot of big business is
looking for the government to step in
and regulate smaller businesses to
protect them breaking with decades of
long-held corporate orthodoxy the
Business Roundtable issued a statement
on the purpose of a corporation arguing
that companies should no longer advance
only the interests of shareholders
instead the group said they must also
invest in their employees protect the
environment and deal fairly and
ethically with their suppliers again I
missed it
where business is not doing this stuff
before if you don't invest in your
employees you know what they do they
leave you know how I know we have
employees here many of the people who
are top level employees in our company
started off as low-level employees in
this company I could name names but I
don't want to embarrass them but there
is tremendous upward mobility at this
company why because we don't want people
to leave we want people to be happy here
despite having to work with me okay the
fact is that if a business does not
protect the environment that business is
going to be regulated into the ground
and that if a business doesn't deal
fairly and ethically with suppliers why
would the supplier deal fairly and
ethically with the business free markets
are based on a root level of trust and
recessive prosity for big businesses to
now come out and issue statements say oh
yeah heretofore we were a moral Gordon
Gekko types but from now on we're just
like Warren Buffett and we're gonna tow
the company line we're gonna tow the
Democratic Party line so we're not
regulated yeah just wait okay the
alligator you keep feeding it it's not
it may eat you last but it'll still eat
you a group says well each of our
individual companies serves its own
corporate purpose we share a fundamental
commitment to all of our stakeholders we
commit to deliver value to all of them
for the future success of our companies
our communities and our country the
shift comes at a moment of increasing
distress in corporate America as big
companies found faced mounting global
discontent over income inequality
harmful products and poor working
conditions okay so why aren't they
pushing back on this I mean this is this
article from the New York Times
explicitly says that these companies are
caving to the propaganda of Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren who by the
way are using iPhones to tweet out their
various campaign stops while driving
around in vehicles made by large
corporations there was no mention at the
roundtable of curbing executive
compensation by the way nor should there
be and the fact is that executive
compensation is market-based and if you
want to look at the dramatic rise in
executive compensation well you really
should look at are the major
corporations like Facebook and Google
where executives have made a bajillion
dollars but you know who else did the
janitors who started working at the
company and who had stock options guys
they're responding to something in the
zeitgeist at Nance
a historian at Harvard Business School
they perceived that business as usual'
is no longer acceptable it's an open
question whether any of these companies
will change the way they do business
well and here is the point right these
businesses think that by cow telling to
the language by basically saying oh
thomas piketty's right income inequality
is our fault we've got to do better that
people will leave them alone good luck
with that good luck with that there is
no end to what people want once you
start feeding them and once you start
once you start feeding the media I don't
mean people generally I mean the media
once you start feeding the media and
Democratic politicians the propaganda
they desire there is no end to how much
you're going to have to feed them more
and more and more and more until they
are taking out vital organs this is all
this is all ridiculous okay but it's
it's ridiculous because we live in a
heavily politicized world and we refuse
to acknowledge the vast good the big
businesses actually do in American
society we crap all over big businesses
despite the fact that they are employing
the vast majority of people in the
United States we crap on people who are
high income earners despite the fact
that the vast majority of those people
have gone in and out of that high income
earning bracket over the course of their
lives and the fact that those are the
people who are providing jobs to other
people those that it is companies that
invest that are creating innovation that
you like but I guess these companies
must be brought to heel and pathetically
the surrender culture is in full swing
do not surrender to the woke brigade do
not surrender to the sjw's when you
surrender to them you are only giving
them the capacity to hang you do you
think by giving them rope that they will
allow you a longer leash incorrect they
are tying the noose for you as we speak
you give people power over your life and
they are going to use it against you and
it is truly amazing I mean you can see
there's never any end of this now I'll
give you an example okay so there's a
guy named Steven Ross right he's the
owner of the Miami Dolphins who's on the
NFL committee committee on social
justice and that committee was dedicated
toward pushing anti-racism anti-sexism
all of us there was no indicator that
Steven Ross had ever done anything wrong
as a member of this committee or that he
had pushed against quote-unquote social
justice for the NFL it turns out that he
held a fundraiser for Trump now he's
been kicked off
long said the NFL social justice
initiative recently got Ross to agree to
remove himself from the group he
shouldn't done it Rasha to stuck around
you should have said you need to force
me out just because I support Donald
Trump does not mean I can't also support
things that I think are good for the
country and we're where we may agree
once you start surrendering to people
the end is nigh for you you got to fight
back and too often in our society people
think the easiest way out is to
apologize for doing stuff that they
didn't do wrong in the first place
really really dumb strategy guys dumb
strategy by big business because I
promise you Elizabeth Warren ain't gonna
care about the nice words you are saying
she's just out there dancing like a
crazy person to Aretha Franklin and
waiting for the moment when she can come
after you that's all okay time for some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so things that I like my wife and
I have been watching the show Hannah
it's based on the 2011 movie I've never
seen the movie I've heard it's pretty
good but the show itself is pretty good
and just like the movie apparently it's
got some sort of weird musical choices
but it definitely is entertaining Joel
Kinnaman is a true star the guy who
plays the father in Hannah he was also
an altered carbon another show that I've
recommended both of these are very
r-rated um and he's terrific and when
people talk about future bonds I've
always thought interest elbow would make
an awesome bond but if not address Elba
no not a female James Bond guys I know
open that can of worms again but Joel
Kinnaman would be a good bond
he really would he's a real action star
and he can act here a little bit the
preview let's talk about your father do
you know why he kept you in the forest
did he tell you where he was going we
are all worried about him
you're safe now she's faking Richards
get out of there it's a very it's a very
intense series and it's a very
action-packed it is pretty good my wife
and I are really enjoying it so go check
it out Hanna on Amazon Prime okay time
for a quick thing that I hate so I gotta
say I do not understand why candidates
feel the need to be something that they
are not and not everyone has to be AOC
dancing on rooftops Elizabeth Warren you
don't have to do this lady I understand
they hijacked a o'seas drinking a beer
in your kitchen while doing an Instagram
video but you don't have to dance lady
you really don't yeah I knew professor
Warren very peripherally when I was at
Harvard Law School she was always pretty
straight-laced she's always very intense
person the first time I met her she
tried to rip into Rush Limbaugh I mean
that's who Elizabeth Warren is her
dancing to Aretha Franklin is one of the
most awkward she's not even Hillary
Clinton 2.0 at this point she's Hillary
Clinton 0.5 like Hillary's an upgrade
like Hillary just getting getting wild
and Cedar Rapids is nothing come oh my
god Wow if you're not watching this
video this is why you should subscribe
because I'm Elizabeth Warren dancing is
one of the worst things you will ever
see it's Elaine from Seinfeld quality
full-on Elaine from Seinfeld quality
don't be what you're not people just be
what you are be a crazy leftist
progressive cynically manipulating the
American people I'm old enough to
remember when Elizabeth Warren was a
moderate yeah that was funny all right
we'll be back here later today with two
additional hours of content I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Caro Mina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily weiter
2019 hey everybody its Andrew Clavin
host of the Andrew Clavin show you know
some people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]